thomas you were here to talk about your
film the hunt it's a very powerful film
with them amazing performance by mads
mikkelsen in there isn't it tell me
about working with him Matt's a
fantastic guy to work with is a huge
enthusiast it's very very eager all the
time you have to get up early as a
director because there's a lot of
questions coming and he's totally
engaged in the process and I really love
working with him and I think he deserves
all the fame that he's getting at the
moment because he's really a good actor
he's tremendous accidentally what kind
of questions is he bringing to you when
he was making the hunt oh all sorts of
questions all the time we we actually
redefined the character for him I roads
one kind of character then Matt's was
attached to the project and and we
rearranged the whole thing and I rewrote
it for him and so it was a long row of
meetings and conversations prior to the
shooting of the film it's tremendously
stylish home as well I want you to talk
a little bit about how you've evolved as
a filmmaker over the years I have been
going through a lot of different stages
of my career if I was a career pilot I
would have crashed many times so what
I've trying I've been trying to do is to
challenge myself I like being on thin
ice and when you're on thin ice you go
through once in a while and I've tried
big success and I've tried the opposite
and I I enjoy the liveliness of that
you